so I'm Jeff Overton Facebook I work on
our JavaScript infrastructure team which
is just a weird way of saying that I
work on JavaScript tools at Facebook and
I'm here to talk to you about just which
is a tool that we've had internally for
actually kind of a couple years now we
use it for testing and I thought it was
really it's really useful and I open
sourced it about two weeks ago mostly
for selfish reasons because I wanted to
use in my personal projects but you guys
can play with it too because it's pretty
cool I think so to start with like
before we get into like what my one of
the most interesting features of just is
I want to go start from the beginning
and talk about like how do like redesign
apps as just like human beings right we
see this app in our head and it's this
vision and we have this idea of like
visualizing this app from the users
perspective but that's different from
how you build the app the way you build
the app is you actually break it down
conceptually into smaller pieces and
these little pieces help us like reason
about the app as we go we can
progressively iterate and like have a
partial prototype that we can play with
and iterate on and so forth and so on
and the way that these pieces usually
manifest themselves at least
historically has been scripts but
recently we have modules as well so we
have these scripts this is this hammer
that we've been given for however long
JavaScript's been around and they're
basically bags of statements and you put
them in you know your HTML page and if
you put a second script you have two
scripts running together and
one of the problems of the scripts is
that they run in this global scope so
they have this this disappointing nature
of like potentially interfering with
each other so really quickly to
illustrate and a simple example let's
say our app we want to be able to log in
and we want to be able to quickly
personalize the app and show the users
name in the app say hello Jeff or
whatever so we write a script it has
this get user object function and it
just talks to the Facebook API and like
gets the the first name of the last name
from the Facebook API this is cool so we
built this we test it we integrate it
with our UI we go play around the
browser while before we check this whole
thing in we try it right this is before
we send their dip out for review or
check it in and we make sure that when
we actually this thing actually works
like if you click login it actually gets
some information from Facebook and says
hello Jeff so that's great it's good we
go on we build our app two months later
we decide well not everybody has
Facebook some people want to use Twitter
some people don't like to use Facebook
that's okay so we just want to get
people's name so we can personalize our
app and pull their name in so we go we
build another library script file very
similar almost identical except this
time it's calling off to the Twitter API
getting from the username and phone the
first name and the last thing that way
so we test this the same way we tested
the Facebook script we go and we play
with it we login with Twitter we see
that says hello Jeff we're good we check
it in we push it and all of a sudden all
of our users start reporting they can't
log in with Facebook damn it what
happened was we over wrote Oh too far
let's do that again
we remember wrote that debt user object
function we were so focused building our
Twitter API library script that we
forgot that we already had a function
name that and scripts clobber each other
but we weren't thinking about that we
wrote it we weren't even thinking about
it we were testing it because we were so
focused on testing the Twitter thing
manually testing that is that we just
put it in there and tested the Twitter
and it worked so we thought we were good
to go
so this is where modules come in and I
don't think I'm telling anybody anything
new here everybody I think or most
people get the Y models are a good thing
they offer these two sort of forms of
isolation they give you the ability to
not clobber other things in your app
which is awesome by default so if I
write a get user object and either these
modules it's not going to clobber each
other but also with all the various
module systems that we have in our
options today which is annoying but
that's another problem they all offer
the ability to explicitly specify how we
interact with the rest of our app so es6
modules am become and yes you can
require import and you can export from
all of these the nice thing about that
is you explicitly identify the things
you want to you want to pull in from the
outside and you explicitly identify the
things that you want the outside to be
able to pull in from you that's really
important in being able to reason about
a small chunk of your app at a small
piece of time but that's how you design
your app let's talk about testing so if
you write some automated tests let's say
we wrote some tests here it's really
useful to have your tests give you some
information about when you're it's when
your application might fail before you
push it off into production so well the
first thing that's beneficial about
tests is that they pass and fail they
give you this immediate indication that
something is wrong with your code before
and it's maybe something that you didn't
even think of it's the Facebook library
broke or whatever but this kind of test
message sucks it's not very specific it
just says the API library failed so
really what we want out of tests we want
that signal of failure but we also want
more information we want to know what
failed let's let's like narrow that
scope down to figure out exactly like if
all we had was that
the the API module failed we have to go
manually figure out how the test
observed that something failed but if we
can write tests that actually give us
this information Twitter API jet user
object never called its callback that
significantly reduces the amount of time
we have to spend trying to figure out
what went wrong and the test did it for
us
so the next question is like well I'll
just recap here basically you have this
sort of debug problem you want to you
find out that a problem or a bug exists
test give you this very quickly and very
easily because they pass or fail the
next question and there the next thing
that you want to do is you want to be
able to reproduce or figure out how that
how to observe that bug if a user sends
your bug report if they just tell you
that your app is broken you don't that's
not useful it's the same thing with
tests so you need to know how the tests
observe that something failed and then
once you have that you can dive in and
find the root cause this is kind of
similar to what Chris shadows talk was
the other day it was like isolating the
area the problem domain and being able
to narrow down to the smallest search
search space um so we have this app and
we need to figure out how we've broken
it down into pieces to build it but now
we need to figure out how to break it
down to pieces that we want to test well
one of the most traditional ways that
you do this is you just observe that you
have these modules and there are these
grooves between them right
each of these orange things is a module
they might talk to each other they have
little sort of links between each other
these but because you have these nice
little separations between these modules
it's very easy to be able to cut them
apart the only thing you have to cut in
those little grooves in between the
modules is the links as those requires
and those imports so this is where it
just comes very useful but one of the
benefits of being able to cut out a
piece of your app is that whenever your
test fails if you know that your test is
only test is only exercising code within
that white square let's say that one
module you know that you've reduced your
server space in your app for the problem
to that white square so now debugging
that test becomes much easier
so where I'm going with this becomes
much more apparent when I actually start
showing you code so here's a very simple
test that will start writing using just
just ships with jasmine
right now at least we are hoping to be
able to make it so that you can plug in
different test frameworks as well but
we'll start with jasmine and if you're
not familiar with jasmine basically the
way you your standard test boilerplate
goes is you write a describe and that's
your test suite in traditional terms and
you have your it which is your spec or
your test and describes or test Suites
can have sets of test specs and tests in
them here we only have one and you see
that we require Facebook API right here
so what we're doing is we're getting
access to this module inside of our test
and this is the module we want to test
but this is the thing we're doing right
now got ahead of myself in real life
what would happen if we did this like in
real life like say no tor browser fire
or whatever what you're going to get
back is an object that looks like this
it has this get user object right and
it's a function and it does this stuff
that we saw earlier but in jest what you
actually get which is interesting and my
favorite part is you don't get that you
get a mock function you don't get the
real thing there's actually problematic
because you want to test the real thing
right here we want to test the Facebook
API but just mocks everything by default
so we have to tell Jess not to mock the
Facebook API but it's cool because we've
told just exactly what we don't want
mocked and everything else just will
just do it for us it's not that magical
the way it works is whenever you require
a function just goes off into like an
isolated environment actually requires
the the module and the reason the
environment is isolated is to make sure
that any side-effects that happen when
you require that module don't affect
your test environment but often secret
it goes off and requires the real module
looks at the exports object that come
out of it that came out of it
says oh there's a get user object
function and then it builds a fake
version
what it saw and that's what it gives you
so when you do things like requiring
other things let's go look at that
Facebook API module that we're requiring
the test at the top of this module will
requiring xhr well in our test
environment when we execute Facebook API
because we've said don't mock it
Facebook API doesn't get the real xhr
module by default and automatically it
gets one that looks like the Facebook
API module and you can see that the
sorry the xhr module you can see the xhr
module has a get function that it
exported well just has generated an just
as automatically generator to get export
for you so if you actually were to call
that function there it wouldn't do
anything it's just mocked and the whole
point here is that you don't want to
exercise any code that isn't in that
white area because if your test fails
you want to be able to be guaranteed
that it's something that you need to
search within the white area not within
your entire app so I've added some
contrived stuff here to make the testing
example simpler to explain but we've I
basically added a user cache here and
I've primed it with information about me
and if you call user object now rather
than always going out to the API and
fetching the information it will go to
the user cache first and if it's there
it'll return it if not it goes off and
gets it so let's see yeah let's go to
the back to the test so coming back to
the test we've required our Facebook ID
API module all of its dependencies have
been automatically blocked so whenever
we do anything with it we're only going
to be executing code within it the next
thing we do is we want to go ahead
because this test is making sure that
our callback function is called we want
to make this mock callback function and
we're using just has a utility for
generating mock functions it's a it's
almost the same thing if you've heard of
jasmine dot create spy it's the same
thing except we just didn't want a
couple just directly to Jasmine so we
included nan couple mocking utilities
creates this mock function all the mock
function does is work
the calls that are made to it and the
arguments that are passed to those calls
so now we're going to call our real
version of Facebook API get user objects
with Jeff Moe which remember I primed so
it's in our cache and then the next
thing we do here is this Jeff stop run
Alzheimer's this is a really cool
feature it's it's really it's just like
I didn't cope with this but somebody
whoever came up with this is it's it's
really neat
basically all we want to do in this test
at this point is wait for that set
timeout zero to go because remember it
was like cached which we contrived for
this example so that set time on zero
isn't going to happen until the next
event loop we don't we don't want to
wait we're just running a test we just
want to fast forward through time just
gives you the ability because you're in
the Jess environment you can run through
all the pending timers and exhaust that
timer queue right now imperative lis in
your tests so you don't the wait there's
no like asynchronous test there's no
like if your test callback never runs
then you have to wait five seconds here
a test if I'm timeout that none of that
nonsense you just run your timers now
and then lastly you can do your expect
you expect that mock callback to have
been called with your stuff and it
should pass let's see so that's how you
that's the high level like the most
interesting feature of just in my
opinion otherwise most of the other
features are just things that you've
probably seen before so but the biggest
benefit to the fact that these things
exist in just in my mind aliases they
come together so you can npm install' GS
CLI you just simply CD into your project
and you're on the just command and it
searches for your tests finds them
execute them it executes them in the
just environment this is very similar to
like the mote the mocha CLI or the
Jasmine node CLI that you might have
seen before and probably lots of others
so let's see yeah you run the you run
the test Runner and searches for your
test it finds them it also executes your
tests in clean environments each time so
every time you run a test file at the
end of that test file it's going to
clean everything up any side effects
that may have happened any modules you
may have required a module state it all
it's cleaned up and then when you run
the next file it it's starting from a
clean state slate so no tests can
interfere by means of side effects with
the next next test see how am i doing on
time I got plenty
what does what this actually gives us
though is the ability to run tests in
parallel so we do by default the just
command line run or not only finds tests
and execute them but actually by default
boots up a worker pool of child
processes this is a node program right
here just as a node node program and it
shells out to those child processes and
runs your tests in parallel and this is
extremely important to us at Facebook
because we have thousands of these tests
and we have to run them like often and
fast so we run our however many thousand
I probably should look that up tests in
well around a minute a little over a
minute
which is pretty cool let's see the the
other interesting aspect of just is
something you might have also seen
before is that it ships with Jazze Dom
so j/s Dom if you haven't heard of it is
a way in node of sort of creating a fake
version of the Dom API and they work so
if you do document aakhri element in in
your test it actually returns an object
it looks like a Dom element so you can
actually write tests on modules that are
actually interacting with the Dom
creating things putting things in a
document that body so forth and so on
and then in your test you just query
selector all for it find it assert that
it did what it was supposed to do and
you can do your test that way that as
well as is cleaned up in each version so
you get a clean version the Dom in each
each run of the test and I should
clarify because I get this question
sometimes when I say we run tests in
parallel we run test files in parallel
we it's it's a very hard problem and I'm
not sure if it's even possible to split
those specs up into parallel but if you
have like this huge test file that takes
a really long time it's it's it's the
quickest optimisation you can do is
split that test in the two so that you
can run both of them parallel
so just to clarify there I think I sped
through that way faster than I expected
so that's the gist of it you can check
out just by installing it npm install' G
you can check out the code and the
documentation and we also most of us
hang out in freenode pound Jess Jas and
I'm not always on my computer but I will
at least try to answer questions and
such yeah I'll bail general I think I'm
done